so we got some crazy news this morning
apparently Ukraine sent a drone to kill
Vladimir Putin fortunately he was not
there he did not die except that's the
narrative coming out of the Kremlin we
don't actually know what really happened
there is the fog of war and many people
are saying either this was a false flag
attack on the Kremlin so that there
would be some kind of justification for
escalation or an attempt to Rally public
support in Russia for the war in Ukraine
or Ukraine actually did make a crude
attempt at taking out Vladimir Putin
either way you can expect some kind of
escalation and there are many people who
are saying oh no this is it this is
World War III and I'm kind of like I
don't know if this is it but an attack
on the Kremlin is fairly serious and if
it wasn't really an attack on on the
Kremlin they're going to act like it was
so still fairly serious but we'll talk
about that